so Fox News article some of you have
seen it and been sending it to me on
Twitter a couple sells all possessions
for sailboat sinks two days into trip a
Colorado couple who dreamed of a life
sailing around the world had the wind
taken out of their sails when their boat
capsized nearly two days into their trip
a couple's plan for a better life has
been sunk but a bunch okay Nikki Walsh
24 and her boyfriend Kenny Tanner
Broadwell 26 decided nearly a year ago
that they were tired of working how can
we live our lives when we work most of
the day and you have to pay so much of
it just to live Walsh said who booked
timeshare tours for a living
most of the work you do just goes to
your home there has to be another option
she added so the Colorado couple sold
all their furniture and their SUV and
purchased a 49 year old boat in Alabama
to live on and eventually sail the world
in the couple moved on to the 28 foot
boat which was in the marina of tarpon
springs a town of Florida's Gulf Coast
lived there for months with their
two-year-old pug Remmy while they
stocked up on food and supplies the
couple had planned their trip for a year
both quitting their jobs and selling all
their worldly possessions in Colorado
before moving out to Florida to live on
their twenty eight foot boat we were
pretty prepared Walsh said of gathering
items to last them for their planned
trip to the Caribbean however the two
were not prepared for what happened next
nearly two days into their venture the
couple's boat capsized in a channel of
water called John's past we thought the
channel was where we were going but it
wasn't walsh told the post telling the
publication they were armed with the gps
and paper navigation charts local boat
captains say the sandbars often shift in
John's past John's pass we started
freaking out because waves were coming
when you weren't on the ocean and it was
tossing our boat back and forth you
wanted to say
both Broadwell was near the rear of the
boat holding on to Remy we're in the
trouble hit my hands were shaking we
were terrified before abandoning ship
the said they grab some clothes and
important documents as well as things
for their dogs I also grabbed Remy's
food just about everything he needed
said wash he doesn't deserve to go
without his favorite toys while she
admitted she and her boyfriend who used
to drive for uber or new to sailing yeah
I think once the most the couple lost
all their material possessions I'm
shouldn't be laughing this is a sad
story the pair said they have $90 and no
jobs and no boat insurance what I
thought you were prepared however the
couple has been left with just 90
dollars in cash no jobs no boat
insurance say they're still hopeful for
their world sailing plans because
they've started a GoFundMe begging
people to give them help them not give
up on their dreams and quotes the pair
is seeking $10,000 to rescue the ship
this is not a ship boys and girls it's a
boat it's 28 feet long it's in four foot
of water sunk off the coast of Madeira
Beach Florida said raising the boat
alone will call $6,700 we've got a lot
of family helping us but it's hard when
you've lost everything you only have one
life why spend it why not spend it doing
what you love why spend it doing what
you don't love money isn't everything he
told the post yeah money isn't
everything why does the GoFundMe there
apparently money just something you need
what I'm having trouble with is their 24
and 26 and they were tired of working
and we're tired of working I mean if you
were 44 and 46 54 and 56 or 64 and 66
but you're 24 you haven't been working
long enough to be tired of working it's
possible but money isn't everything boat
insurance is but that costs money but
money isn't everything you know so this
is so hard to not be harsh I just want
to be funny
instead of being harsh it's just it's
but it's so sad because I can tell you
I've done so many stupid things in my
life and the list of stupid things in
this story is so long and every time I
do something stupid you don't need the
guys it costs it brings me pain and cost
me money
and that's what happened to these guys
so my prayer for them is that no one
gives them a dime for their GoFundMe
account because these two really just
don't like to work much they're not very
responsible they you know when we get
off the boat the main thing we do is we
save the pugs toys because the Pug
doesn't deserve that pug doesn't deserve
to be with you people like your
irresponsible
pugs are great I like pugs he doesn't
deserve to go without his favorite toys
this is what's occurring to her as her
boat is sinking without insurance the
Pug toys it's somebody will give this
you have money they just go fund me I'm
sure because you only have one life why
spending it why spend it doing what you
don't love money isn't everything no
it's not everything and you shouldn't
spend your whole life doing what you
don't love but unless like your goal is
to not work ever and have other people
give you money so you can sail around
the Caribbean and call that fulfillment
that's not gonna work out for you I
can't imagine having a 24 year old
daughter and coming in and telling me
hey Dad my boyfriend and I are going to
the Caribbean we have no clue what we're
gonna do
and we think we're prepared and we just
don't want to work much I could just
break my heart because here's what's
gonna happen these people are going to
be it's gonna take them a decade to
recognize that they're gonna have to
work work is not a bad thing work gives
you dignity work is where money comes
from not GoFundMe and you know and if
you call yourself prepared but you are
have no idea how to sale and yet you're
sailing and you forgot to buy insurance
on your boat or just chose not to you're
what we call sunk problems right I mean
really oh gosh so I hope I hope they I
hope yeah the problem is your dreams
become your nightmares when you don't
know how to live life like an adult
that's the problem and adults devise a
plan and follow what children do what
feels good these are a couple of
children and I'm not making fun of them
I'm not picking on them it's just it's
just sad and what's sad is is it's
actually a new story and I'm so stupid I
actually read it so and then took a
whole segment of the show on it but you
know the point is is that sometimes I'm
poor sometimes I struggle with money
because of my stupidity sometimes I
struggle with money because of my lack
of character sometimes I struggle with
money because other people take
advantage of me sometimes I struggle
with money because of the situation I
was born into and I haven't learned to
rise above that particular situation yet
so there's legitimate reasons that
people are poor that are not their fault
not these two these two a hundred
percent of it is their fault and that's
pretty much stupid tax on steroids right
there and and I hate I was older than
that when I lost everything because I
was stupid and I lost a lot more than
that and for a lot of different reasons
but yeah it's done
folks you're gonna be doing work and
then your if you're smart once you get
your bills paid then you'll start doing
work that you do love and that you do
care about and that does have meaning
but you're gonna be doing work it gives
you dignity it causes your brain to work
and it causes you to be able to live
your dreams rather than somebody else's
nightmare what a mess this is the Dave
Ramsey show
[Music]